you have it hard yet on the One
Direction Facebook page there's a thing
about how Zayn is leaving the band did
you hear the news
Zayn is leaving 1d and the rest of the
boys are gonna continue on as a foursome
I guess whatever that means
why why I'm sorry this is terrible news
all right here's a supercut of reactions
to the break-up never has there been
anything so hard to wake up to what Hey
look at this
you both look right without him
I wish I was dead just doesn't make
sense
but surely someone told me was true like
I'm going through the first stage of
depression they'll always leave us but
if for him when he wants to come home
well guess I'm not fan of One Direction
anymore
I love you Zane I love you hey you know
good for him huh huh shake it off guys
if you miss the old 1d like me hit like
comment with your reaction to this
heartbreaking news subscribe to get more
super cuts or 1d coverage and the latest
in Internet news ho it's coming back Wow
this isn't fair like what necks are
gonna tell me that Perry and Taylor
Swift wrote up right